la position constante de la france se
considérer que les vaccins c'est un bien
public mondial
et c'est évidemment très important tout
la table dimension des dimensions de
production des dimensions de circulation
des dimensions d'utilisation et
naturellement la dimension qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui autour des droits de
propriété intellectuelle et en
particulier des breuvages eux je vais je
vais commencer quand même pas rappeler
que cette position bien public mondial
pour les vaccins ça se traduit d'abord
par les dons et ça se traduit de manière
d'avoir parce qu'on en fait au titre de
la solidarité internationale et on en
fait beaucoup et le plus rapidement
possible et deuxièmement qu'on ait fait
comme beaucoup d'autres pays à travers
ce qu'on appelle la facilité kovacs qui
est d'un instrument de de
circularisation t doses qui est lui-même
multilatéral donc donc on joue vraiment
doublement j'ai envie de dire ce que
cette politique de bien public mondial
au titre de notre solidarité via les
dons le deuxième élément c'est
évidemment les exportations je parlais
de circulation bien public mondial tout
à l'heure et là il faut souligner sous
le contrôle de monsieur thalmann sous
contrôle de monsieur houben en
particulier que l'europe est d'une
certaine manière exemplaire puisqu'elle
exporte en gros la moitié de sa
production
ça n'était pas du tout le sujet des
preuves des brevets mais ça leur cadre
aussi c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de
restrictions aux exportations soit des
produits finis soit des intrants en
france et un dispositif d'autorisation
qui a été quasiment dans 99% des cas
validé j'en viens au sujet de la
production
si vous le voulez bien et donc le
premier élément c'est de se dire quand
le dg de l'om s10 vacciner vacciner
vacciner nous on a envie de dire aussi
produire produire produire et donc au
delà des éléments de solidarité
d'exportation cette production repose
sur des capacités qui sont réelles et
évidemment des savoir-faire au coeur
desquels on trouve la propriété
intellectuelle là dessus sur la
propriété intellectuelle président de la
république ministre de l'économie mise
la santé la mise de l'industrie que je
représente et qui vous salue
matelly en préparant notre notre
audition il
toujours dit la propriété intellectuelle
qui a des brevets ils doivent en aucun
cas être un obstacle ou même un frein à
la vaccination et à la lutte une fois la
peau d'amis à tous les efforts
coordonnés pour en sortir le plus
rapidement possible il ya quatre au
point sur le sujet je le détaillerai si
vous le voulez bien rapidement un par un
le premier il a été largement abordée
celle et flexibilité dans le cadre des
tic
le deuxième et ça fera référence aussi à
ce qu'a dit ido juste avant moi
le mécanisme ou la facilité dit des
licences obligatoires
il ya un troisième sujet qu'on n'a pas
abordé encore sur lequel j'essayerai
d'intervenir qui est celui des intrants
et enfin la position
j'ai envie d'air de la france par
rapport à celle de la commission
européenne par rapport à la troisième
voie qui est porté par le dg de l'om
c'est aujourd'hui sur c'est sur ces
sujets là donc si j'en viens maintenant
au premier sujet celui des flexibilités
alpiq
nous on pense que il ya déjà pas mal
d'éléments qui sont intéressants et
président le bleu vous l'avez déjà aussi
largement abordée et repréciser la suite
de l'intervention de ito juste avant moi
il ya il ya des éléments en termes de
recours à l'expertisé de licences
volontaire ou de flexibilité pour pas
dire de dérogation dans un cadre
extrêmement limité il faut absolument
activé au sein au sein des dispositifs
omc ou dans des réflexions d'ailleurs
que je souligne un peu similaire ou d'un
ordre analogue qui sont en cours de
structuration du côté de l'om est
également le deuxième point est l' idole
a largement évoqué c'est celui
effectivement de ce que permet
aujourd'hui le mécanisme dit de licences
obligatoires
donc je vais pas je vais pas faire un
article trop long sur le sujet d'autant
que le temps de mon intervention est
content et je pense que ça parle à tout
le monde mais c'est de dire que c'est à
la main des gouvernements qui souhaitent
produire localement des vaccins ils
peuvent demander bien ce mécanisme la
levée des brevets qui est un outil
parfaitement légitime en tout cas de la
france considère comme parfaitement
légitime la disposition des
gouvernements concernés
le troisième point est celui sur
lesquels on n'est peut-être pas beaucoup
intervenu c'est celui des intrants alors
on est on est connexe 1 par rapport au
strict question propriété intellectuelle
et
et je vous prie d'accepter mes excuses
pour pour définir un tout petit peu mais
c'est un sujet absolument stratégique
on est d'accord qu'il faut des usines on
est d'accord qu'il faut des compétences
sont d accord qu il faut des équipements
mais on est d'accord aussi et surtout
qu'il faut des matières premières et sur
le sujet des intrants critique
aujourd'hui on est pas tous à égalité et
la circulation des intrants qui est
l'une des conditions premières de la
capacité d'avoir une production répartie
et abondante ne nous paraissent
aujourd'hui pas complètement réunies
encore ou complètement sécurisé encore
donc il ya un énorme sujets autour des
intrants et des incertitudes sur les
intrants je pense que c'est un peu
transparent pour tout le monde mais on
peut penser à des dispositifs de type
différence protection act sur le sujet
qui j'ai envie de dire sont susceptibles
non pas de mettre en péril mais de
rendre surtout un peu incertain des
chaînes de production extrêmement
exigeante étendu pour sécuriser la
chaîne de qualité et d'efficacité de la
production vaccinale tout au long de son
cheminement et est donc pour nous c'est
également un obstacle un obstacle
important ça veut pas dire que le sujet
la propriété intellectuelle en est pas
un mais on a évoqué la flexibilité
appliquée et notamment le mécanisme de
vicence obligatoire et pour revenir sur
le sujet des brevets plus strictement
est au coeur de nos discussions
aujourd'hui de votre audition du jour le
sujet donc delà de la troisième voie qui
est engagée et porté par le directeur
général de l'om c'est donc pour
renforcer une manière concrète la
coopération entre acteurs publics
industrie pharma et bailleurs de fonds
pour développer la production de vaccins
et aussi les capacités de production
partout hein c'est pas que c'est pas que
la circulation les exportations c'est
aussi la capacité à se doter de
capacités production partout sur le
globe
dans cette optique donc la commission
européenne sous le contrôle de tito a
présenté le 4 juin dernier une
communication à l'om c'est avec
l'initiative globale sur ce sujet
permettant d'adresser les difficultés
rencontrées dans l'accès aux traitements
et aux vaccins en facilitant le commerce
intérieur à la section des exportations
je pense que j'en ai abondamment parlé
l'extension des capacités de production
je viens encore de le révoquer et
surtout pour ce qui nous occupe la
clarification des règles relatives aux
licences obligatoires dont clairement en
ligne avec ce que je venais de préciser
avant
sur la corde et alpiq au-delà de ça bon
la france soutient évidemment et vous
avez vu les interventions récentes
notamment du président larcher 7 en fin
de semaine dernière
je suis prêt à répondre évidemment à
toutes vos questions sur le sujet mais
elles me paraissent particulièrement
claire par elle-même et pour elle-même
et a ajouté à cet égard on travaille
aussi beaucoup en bilatérale ou
multilatérale ou bilatérale aussi à la
création de projet d'une usine de
vaccins notamment dans les pays du sud
notamment en afrique et notamment en
particulier au sénégal et en afrique du
sud pour pour développer là bas la
production de vaccin contre la folie de
19 l'afrique qui représente 20% des
besoins ne dispose à ce jour de capacité
de production que pour en produire 1 %
vous ça met en évidence à mon avis et
pour conclure deux points essentiels
1 la nécessité d'avoir des capacités de
production et j'ai envie de dire les
recettes permise par le mécanisme des
licences obligatoires en particulier et
puis deuxièmement dans l'intervalle
d'avoir une très très grande fluidité
amour et aval des éléments qui sont
absolument critique pour la production
et la finalisation d'un produit aussi
important aujourd'hui que les vaccins et
que la france comme d'autres considèrent
comme étant réellement un public mondial
merci un grand merci à monsieur cunéo
effectivement la position de la france
on le comprend aborde différents aspects
et pas simplement l'aspect de propriété
intellectuelle et je remercie car
effectivement il faut élargir le débat
puisque l'objectif est la vaccination et
l'immunité collective mondiale et que
dans ce contexte la propriété
intellectuelle n'est qu'un aspect de
du sujet et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est important d'élargir on
note effectivement qu'il y à une
concordance avec l'idée précédemment
évoqués de flexibiliser les accords at
pic
l'idée est également de permettre
peut-être de faciliter les licences
d'office
il y aura une question et ce sera plutôt
dans le cadre des questions réponses
ultérieure nous serons très intéressé
par avoir des précisions sur le point 3
c'est à dire concernant les intrants et
puis enfin le le point 4 effectivement
là encore on reprend des éléments
évoqués précédemment par monsieur houben
concernant la position de l'union
européenne auprès de l'om sait et qui
concerne l'idée de capacités de
production partout mais nous aborderons
nous préciserons ces points-là
ultérieurement dans la phase 2 de
questions réponses en tout cas merci à
vous monsieur cunéo pour toutes ces
précisions
nous allons maintenant avoir
l'opportunité d'écouter la position de
monsieur mathieu guerriau maître de
conférences en droit pharmaceutique et
de la santé
pharmacovigilance et il y a trop génie à
l'université de bourgogne franche comté
bonjour mesdames et messieurs messieurs
les présidents villes amies et le bleu
est ce que vous voyez bien en écran oui
nous vous nous voyons votre écran je
vais vous présenter en fait la fête se
dire que rarement intitulé à la levée
des obligations et des licences
obligatoires et poser la question si
elles sont vraiment des solutions
premièrement quels sont les moyens qui
sont à notre disposition en matière de
propriété intellectuelle pour
sauvegarder la santé publique ils sont
essentiellement aux nombres de leucate
mais ils n'ont pas les mêmes effets les
mêmes impacts sur le brevet est sûre le
propriétaire du brevet est alors il ya
bien évidemment les licences
obligatoires et les licences d'office et
d'ailleurs là encore en français nous
détaillons plus qu'au niveau d'anglais à
ces deux licences puisque là ils sont
obligatoires en droit français qu'on
l'exportation et la licence de fist
plutôt le marché intérieur il y a
également et de façon plus attentatoires
à la propriétaire des industriels la
réquisition qui en droit français a été
permis par la loi d'urgence 23 mars 2010
elle a un caractère temporaire va au
delà du brevet puisque ont dû
réquisitionner arts-loi forcé des
entreprises industrielles privées avec
la mise à disposition du personnel
encore un cran au dessus il y à
l'expropriation de brevets qui peut être
mise en oeuvre pour des besoins alors en
france de défense nationale sachant que
la défense nationale est une notion
suffisamment large puisqu'elle va bien
au delà des matériels de guerre et enfin
dernier point la nationalisation et je
vais pas aborder
je vais pas m'appesantir sur les trois
derniers points mais plutôt sur le
premier point puisque c'est le point qui
pose principal problème actuellement au
niveau des accords elle fixe sont les
licences obligatoires et je voudrais
montrer deux exemples d'utilisation des
licences obligatoires par le patient
deux exemples frappante la première
utilisation en fête a eu lieu dans un
contexte très particulier qu'est le
contexte des années 2000 où il y à une
propagation du vih et donc la maladie
sida explose et les trithérapies coûte
extrêmement cher et juste après la
déclaration de doha le premier pays à
utiliser la licence obligatoire sera la
malaisie qui en 2003 en fait tu
demanderas ou à l'inde est un
laboratoire qui s'appelle cipla
demandera de produire des
antirétroviraux le laboratoire indien
reproduira les antirétroviraux qui sera
ensuite expédiée vers la malaisie à un
coût bien évidemment extrêmement
inférieur à ce que la malaisie aurait dû
payer si elle achetait le lavables
médicaments princeps le médicament
original
le deuxième exemple toujours dans le
même contexte c'est celui du brésil qui
est un tout petit peu différente
puisqu'il va d'abord faire appel de 2007
à 2009
alain dhée là encore pour produire un
antirétroviral qui s'appelle les
familles rennes ce qui est le générique
du sustiva aujourd'hui générique
puisqu'à l'époque je ne l'étais pas et
le brésil va encore me demander à l'inde
mais cette fois ci un autre laboratoire
robin dodo
d'huile ce médicament est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le brésil avait tenté
au préalable de négocier avec le
propriétaire du médicament une baisse de
prix mais on va ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'à partir de 2009 le brésil n'a
plus besoin de l'inde et va produire lui
même
en réalité ce médicament après avoir
fait de la rétro-ingénierie c'est à dire
après avoir décortiqué si vous préférez
15 la rétro-ingénierie comment le
médicament était produit et donc on
vient de voir deux petits exemples il y
en avait beaucoup d'autres à vous
montrer je n'ai pas le temps qu'ils ont
eu des effets remarquables sur les prix
de médicaments et qui ont facilité
l'accès à ces médicaments grâce à la
baisse des prix aux populations malades
et ce qui est intéressant également
s'est par la suite
beaucoup d'états membres même pas eu
besoin de l'utiliser la licence
obligatoire ou licences d'office
en réalité ils ont simplement dit qu'il
souhaitait l'utiliser pour que les
laboratoires fasse des concessions et
baisse de même les on vient me voir donc
que la licence obligatoire office est
très efficace pour faire baisser les
prix
malheureusement je vais tenter de vous
démontrer que cette ses licences
obligatoires ou la levée des obligations
n'auront pas d'utilité dans la
production des vaccins en tout cas à
court terme
pourquoi bien premièrement parce que le
brevet n'est pas une solution clé en
main
en effet le problème n'est pas savoir
faire le brevet ne contient que très peu
d'informations techniques
en réalité le brevet ne contient pas le
mode d'emploi pour la fabrication d'un
médicament et on l'a bien compris avec
les intervenants précédemment un
médicament
ça n'est pas simplement la substance
active c'est la substance active les
excipients
et n'oublions pas non plus le
conditionnement des flaconnages qui sont
réussies des éléments qu'il faut
produire donc un médicament c'est
quelque chose de particulièrement
complexe produire les ingrédients près
du port durée substances actives
produire les excipients le formuler et
ensuite le mettre en flacon tout ça est
extrêmement complexe et ça n'est pas
dans les brevets qu'on retrouve ces
informations ces informations sont dans
ce qu'on appelle le savoir faire ce
savoir-faire il est propre à
l'entreprise titulaire du ou des brevets
parfois assez façonniers donc ses sous
traitants et donc un brevet n'est pas la
solution clé en main
ça n'est pas un qui pour faire
nikam alors cela est en vie on peut
quand même
transféré du savoir faire et la solution
pour transférer du savoir faire c'est le
transfert de technologie le transfert de
technologie donc le mot clé le seul
problème c'est que ce transfert de
technologie vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président le lui en introduction il ne
peut être que volontaire parce qu'on ne
peut pas forcer à faire du transfert de
technologie en plus on se heurterait au
secret des affaires
il faut que le titulaire du brevet
accepte alors c'est là où il ya
nécessité de travailler avec
l'industriel les industriels et non pas
contre eux et il faut imaginer des
mécanismes d'incitation au transfert de
technologie soi qui existe qui
n'existent pas soit existe peu en tout
cas il faut réinventer ces mécanismes
pour favoriser le transfert de
technologie sur le long terme et si on
prend l'exemple du vaccin arn le les
vaccins qui sont aujourd'hui distribués
majoritairement france
ce transfert de technologie est
fondamental car on ne produit pas de la
gare de messagerie comme on veut c'est
assez facile d'en produire dans un
laboratoire de recherche comme dans une
université
mais passer à l'échelle industrielle
c'est le production est beaucoup plus
complexe c'est ce qu'on appelle le scale
up
d'ailleurs les industriels ont eu
énormément de mal à trouver des sous
traitants qui soit capable de fabriquer
en grosse quantité cet arn messager on a
trouvé certes certains comme lonza mais
il y en a très peu et donc il va falloir
travailler sur des formes de coopération
est passé par la licence volontaires
bien plus que par la licence obligatoire
bien sûr quand cela est possible
il ya tout de même un écueil à ce
transfert de technologie je voulais déjà
dit c'est que ça prend énormément de
temps
ce transfert de technologie prend des
années parce que si on veut transférer
cette technologie dans les pays du sud
il faudra construire une usine ou en
reconvertir unis donc il faudra qualifié
d' usine d'un point de vue réglementaire
d'un point de vue normatif il faudra
qualifié le matériel il faudra peut-être
leur qualifiée pour répondre aux
exigences minimales de production des
médicaments et dans le cas d'un vaccin
c'est encore pire puisque c'est un
médicament injectable
il faut un traitement drastique de l'eau
pour produire un vaccin ce qu'on appelle
de l'eau éveillé pour préparation
injectables il faut un traitement de
l'air à tout à toute épreuve
or d'ailleurs dans les pays du sud les
conditions climatiques ne nous aide
vraiment pas puisque les températures
sont supérieures à 35 degrés d'humidité
latif de l'air supérieures à 4 ans à
coursan donc ça veut dire que le
traitement de l'air va être très
complexe faut savoir c'est qu'en france
c'est déjà complexe d'assurer le
traitement de l'air il ya souvent des
pannes qu'on doit résoudre en
catastrophe dans les pays du sud ce sera
encore plus difficile qu'il faut aussi
savoir c'est que la production de
médicaments la production industrielle
l'industrie du médicament et sans doute
avec l'aéronautique l'industrie la plus
normé de par le monde et ce dans le seul
but de la sécurité des nations donc sur
ce point là la levée des obligations la
levée la levée des brevets sans
transfert de savoir-faire de technologie
ne sert à rien il faut des licences
volontaire il faut de la coopération
il faut de l'incitation le deuxième
point qui est très scientifique celui là
et qui posera un énorme problème c'est
qu'un vaccin n'est pas une petite
molécule chimique
en effet un vaccin c'est un médicament à
part entière c'est un médicament qui
plus est biologique un médicament
immunologique c'est une définition à
casquette et le problème c'est qu'il ya
une énorme différence entre un
médicament qu'on va appeler chimie donc
un médicament de synthèse et un
médicament biologique en effet un
médicaments chimiques
c'est un médicament donc chimiquement
défini qui est très stable qui est très
petit vous aimez un exemple ici
l'oxycodone qui est une petite molécule
énorme avantage une très grande
reproductibilité au niveau industriel de
très grande facilité contrôle
en revanche les médicaments biologiques
de par sa nature même biologique est
variable et il est infiniment plus grand
josé miel à l'écran ici l'insuline qui
tout en étant plus grande qu'une mode
est une petite molécule chimique est une
petite molécule biologique
si j'avais voulu montrer un virus comme
dans le vive le vaccin astrazeneca
il m'aurait fallu des dizaines de
diapositives remplies pour pouvoir
montrer toute sa structure
donc c'est impossible et le problème
donc un du biologique c'est la très
grande variabilité le risque de
contamination
alors certes on sait faire un petit peu
de copies de biologique c'est ce qu'on
appelle les lieux similaires mais
aujourd'hui sur le marché des
biosimilaires qu'on sait faire
ce sont des biosimilaires de petites
molécules biologiques nous n'avons
jamais à ce jour copier de vaccin car
les éléments du vaccin sont infiniment
plus grands et les plus complexes
et en plus la réglementation de vaccins
comme vous l'avez vue est un médicament
en plus d'être biologique immunologique
il y à des procédures particulières de
culture de purification et l'analyse en
somme si je veut résumer cette
diapositive copier du chimique avec une
licence de fils obligatoire c'est
possible qu'au pied du biologique
c'est quasiment mission impossible donc
en conclusion la licence d'office
obligatoire ou les listes les levée
d'obligation ont un but très intéressant
c'est faire chuter les prix se sont donc
ce qu'on appelle des armes de dissuasion
il suffit de brandir la menace pour
faire baisser les prix en revanche ce ne
sont pas des arts médiatiques
elles ne pourront pas répondre aux
problèmes de pénurie et de manque de
production c'est clair et précis elles
ont permis par le passé de copier du
chimique car c'était facile qu'au pied
du biologique
ce sera beaucoup plus combler ce en tout
cas en l'état voire impossible comme je
voulais montrer aussi le brevet n'est
pas une solution clé en main les
licences ne prennent pas en compte le
savoir faire il ne faut pas négliger les
problématiques de ce colloque donc de
passage à l'échelle industrielle
les problématiques de terrain et surtout
il ne faut pas négliger la
réglementation du médicament et
l'ampleur normative qu'il ya autour de
cette réglementation il faudra
privilégier la négociation plutôt que le
rapport de force qui va éviter d éviter
de contribuer à une perte de confiance
des industriels dans le marché car ses
repères de confiance risquerait lors
d'une prochaine pandémie arrive de mon
investissement à risque de non
d'innovation et donc les propositions
pour terminer c'est qu'il faudrait
davantage recourir licence volontaire
plutôt que licence obligatoire inciter à
la coopération travailler avec les
industriels et pas contre eux et il faut
assez tôt promouvoir le transfert de
technologie sur le long terme ce qui
laisse tout de même le temps d'exploiter
le brevet d'avoir un retour sur
investissement et il faudra imaginer des
incitations et pour aller plus loin
quelques publications et je vous
remercie pour votre attention je
remercie également le professeur fortier
qui m'a beaucoup aidé pour cette
présentation
je crois que tous autour de cette table
quel que soit notre notre point de vue
notre position nous poursuivons le même
objectif
l'objectif de vacciner le plus
rapidement possible la plus grande
population possible à l'échelle
planétaire dans les meilleures
conditions d'efficacité et de sécurité
possibles
mais j'ajouterais pour ce qui nous
concerne plus particulièrement tant
qu'entreprise du médicament de maintenir
également une capacité de recherche qui
nous permettent de faire face à
l'émergence de nouveaux variants qui ne
cesse de faire leur apparition depuis le
début de la pandémie
autrement dit nous sommes confrontés à
un problème ou une problématique unique
chimie ni économique ni moral ni
idéologique probable en parle
probablement pas non plus d'ailleurs
juridique mais bien sanitaires et notre
objectif partagé doit être celui de
l'efficacité
alors pour commencer évidemment ce débat
ne doit pas nous faire oublier les soit
extraordinaire qui a constitué d'amis
d'enfants en un an d'un vaccin pour
faire face à un virus nouveau inconnu
jusqu alors vous savez qu'il s'écoule
habituellement 10 ans entre l'invention
d'un bassin et ses diffusions sur la
surface de la planète
s'agissant des vaccins qui sont
aujourd'hui en phase 4 il s'est écoulé
moins de 12 mois alors on ne va pas ici
qu'on n'est pas sur moi en tout cas pour
distribuer les les bons et les mauvais
points
ce résultat il a été obtenu par la
mobilisation de tous face à la menace la
recherche académique
les sociétés de biotechnologie les
entreprises pharmaceutiques et cette
mobilisation elle a entraîné les
partenariats public privé mais aussi
d'ailleurs dé partenariat privé privé
sans précédent certaines de ces
recherches ont bénéficié de financements
publics d'autres parfois d'ailleurs les
plus couronnés succès rapidement
non ces recherches ont pu aussi
s'appuyer sur d'importantes commandes
publiques d'aval mais tout et je dis
bien toutes ont représenté une prise de
risque colossal pour les entreprises
c'est ont dû réaliser de lourds
investissements en simultané condé une
urgence sanitaire
pour prendre un exemple il nous a fallu
augmenter nos capacités de production
sans certitude d'aboutir à
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
pour les candidats restants ces
résultats ils sont d'autant plus
remarquables qu'elles ont été atteints
en respectant les trois fondamentaux qui
doit réunir tous produites sont émis sur
le marché de qualité efficacité et
sécurité
et ne nous berçons pas d'illusions le
succès à pattaya et est toujours au
rendez-vous alors nous parlons n'y a que
quatre vaccins qui ont obtenu une
autorisation de mise sur le marché est
conditionnel hors d'europe
même si et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle nous avons moins d'espoir de
voir arriver prochainement d'où la
solution vaccinale
les chiffres lui seront souvent donne un
peu le vertige
alors où nous parlons il y a dans le
monde 318 candidats en essais
précliniques 33 en phase 1 25
en face d'eux un deux dix en phase 2 kg
est en phase 2 3 16 en phase iii et cinq
candidats en phase 4 donc vous voyez
l'effort de recherche colossal qui a
généré 7 cette pandémie
411 tentative d'innovation et je ne
tiens pas compte ici de celles qui ont
été stoppée faute de preuves ou de
démonstration d'efficacité de qualité ou
de sécurité et donc une mobilisation de
cette industrie qu'elle était une
mobilisation extraordinaire et une
démonstration que c'est l'innovation
assise sur des collaborations tous
azimuts qui a servi l'intérêt de
planétaire alors j'en viens aux
problématiques de production et sans
reprendre ce que disait monsieur
bériault et qu'il a parfaitement
expliquée au travers de ces quelques
slides
il est clair que dès le début de la
crise notre industrie était consciente
ce serait nécessaire d'augmenter dans un
temps record ses capacités de
fabrication
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur
parce qu'on a l'impression parfois dans
nos discussions que l'un tout ça est un
peu magique mais il faut il fallait nous
devions triplet tripler la capacité de
mondial de production de vaccins de
vaccin sûr et de vaccins efficaces
autrement dit les industriels dès le
lancement des projets de recherche
compte engager deux types dation d'abord
le partage des capacités de production
et ça c'est un phénomène sans précédent
dans notre industrie et d'autre part la
multiplication des partenariats à chaque
fois que cela est possible pour
augmenter ou accélérer la production des
vaccins alors on nous parlons et je
reviens sur ces accords
deux licences volontaire à l'heure où
nous parlons près de 300 acteurs de 300
accords de partenariat incluant des
transferts de technologies dont plus de
deux tiers des cas ont été mis en place
par l'industrie pharmaceutique depuis le
début de la pandémie et il faut une très
clair et ça a été très bien expliquée
par monsieur roland paradoxalement
peut-être par rapport aux raisonnements
majoritaire d'une accord d'une nature
tout à fait inédit qu'il est très clair
que ces accords n'aurait pas été rendue
possible sans un dispositif solide de
défense de la propriété intellectuelle
et les partenariats vous savez ils ont
été très variés partenariat entre
concurrents qui mobilisent leurs moyens
pour développer et produire des vaccins
semble partenariats entre entreprises et
organismes publics de recherche
on a beaucoup parlé d'astra et de
l'université d'oxford takeda travaille
aujourd'hui avec novavax et nissarda
santé japonais partenariat entre au sein
des bébés des grands ont des grandes
puissances vaccinale novartis est curé
vague sanofi travail haifa isr modern
art où du angie et partenariats aussi
avec des continents en développement par
exemple jmj a passé des accords avec
aspen en afrique du sud
as raté avec les soirées site de
huningue et donc c'est ainsi qu'elle a à
la fin du mois de mai 2,2 milliards de
doses avait déjà été produites dans le
monde
il nous sommes aujourd'hui
raisonnablement optimiste pour penser
que nous arriverons à produire 10
milliards de doses d'ici la fin de
l'année 2021
ce qui permettra paix au rythme en je
dis bien taylorisme ans c'est-à-dire à
répartition équitable de vacciner toute
la population adulte mondiale
alors si on parle maintenant économie
moi je m'interroge un petit peu pour
pour lancer le débat
personne n'a jamais soulevé la
problématique de la gratuité des masques
de protection de la gratuité des tests
des pistes de dépistage même de la
gratuité des traitements destinés aux
personnes malades et le vaccin oms est
prête le flanc à beaucoup de beaucoup de
critiques beaucoup de fantasmes beaucoup
de représentations idéologiques je
constate que ceux qui sont les plus
ardents a demandé la levée des rôles des
brevets ont souvent aider ceux qui ont
donné crédit aux thèses complotistes sur
les vaccins
il l'a encore les chiffres parlent au
plan économique la crise qu'ovide 19 en
france est évalué à 158 milliards
d'euros à mettre en perspective avec le
coût global de la vaccination publié
récemment par le comité d' alerte de
l'ondam à 4,6 milliards d'euros
fort 70% de la population nationale tous
les préventes au sérieux vous diront
donc que la vaccination est sans doute
l'une des approches les plus coût
efficace en santé il pour revenir à la
problématique des licences deux fils
dont parlait très bien monsieur
guerrière tout à l'heure je rappellerai
que les vaccins conventionnelles sont
vendues un petit couteau et les vaccins
rl le sonde appris à différencier mais
qu'il n'y a pas de problématique de prix
pour la src l'achat nous sommes en face
de contraintes technologiques
donc qu'est-ce que l'on doit lever c'est
bien le thème de cette table ronde les
brevets pour régler la crise sanitaire
je pense qu'il faut il faut dépasser
pour répondre à cette question les
présupposés idéologiques et ça a été dit
dans cette table ronde je voudrais
reprendre les points qu'il faut se poser
les bonnes questions
est ce qu'il existe des réserves a fini
de matières premières pour répondre à
l'explosion de la demande dans une
hypothèse que nous considérons comme non
réaliste et d'augmentations drastique
des capacités de production la réponse
est non
les matières premières nécessite un
temps de fabrication et un savoir faire
de haut niveau pour être incorporé dans
le produit fini ce ne sera pas le cas
est ce que la vie des brevets permet
d'augmenter la production
non parce que l'accélération de la
production et c'était mieux dit que je
le ferai avant avant moi
l'accélération de la production passe au
contraire par des partenariats
volontaire et collaboratif entre
innovateurs à l'origine des vaccins et
fabricants qui c'est vrai importe une
expertise propre et les capacités de
production et que c'est justement la
garantie des droits de propriété
intellectuelle qui nous a permis ce type
d'accord avant la garantie que la levée
des brevets n'entraîne pas la risque
majeur de contrefaçon non la
globalisation multiplient risc group de
contrefaçon et accroît d'ailleurs la
nécessité
ou du recours à la protection juridique
des inventions je rappelle pour prendre
un exemple très concret qu'en 1993
une campagne de vaccination niger avec
déjà senti méningococcique contrefaits
en provenance d'un pays voisin avait
généré 3000 décès est ce que il existe
des capacités dormantes de production ou
pourrait mobiliser en levant les brevets
non parce que là encore ça a été dit le
savoir-faire les compétences de haut
niveau sont nécessaires il que les
ressources humaines au delà des
capacités de production sont elles aussi
limité
est-ce que et c'est un point majeur dans
notre point de vue est ce que les
projets actuellement en phase d'essai
préclinique dont je parlais tout à
l'heure pourraient être poursuivis en
cas de levée des brevets
probablement non parce que sans
perspective économique juridique stable
tout porteur de projet verrait sa prise
de risque non récompensés et donc on
tuerait dans l'oeuf de nombreuses
innovations prometteuses qui dont vous
ferez défaut en cas de survenue de
nouveaux variants est ce que les levées
les brevets d'une bonne solution
dans la situation actuelle nous trouvons
non il est clair que des pays en
développement ont besoin d'un soutien ce
soutien passe par une politique de dons
de vaccins par la multiplication de
partenariat qui sont beaucoup plus
vertueux de notre point de vue que la
disparition des mécanismes de protection
juridique de l'innovation la question de
l'industrialisation des pays en
développement elle est réelle elle
prendra du temps
je ne pense pas que nous soyons dans les
belles et là aussi ça a été dit pour
pouvoir répondre en temps utile ou à la
menace pandémique
enfin est-ce que la levée libreville
prépare l'avenir non parce que c'est
justement la garantie des droits de
propriété les actuels qui nous a permis
de réagir rapidement à la menace
pandémique
sa remise en hausse fragiliserait en
réalité l'ensemble du système de santé
face aux menaces futures autrement
livres y compris dans mon propos la
levée des provinces c'est à tous points
de vue une très mauvaise réponse à un
très grand problème
alors nous avons bien sûr
des solutions les solutions existent
nous avons cinq recommandations et je
terminerai par l'amour propos la
première recommandation c'est
d'intensification des partages des doses
ça a été dit et le redit aujourd'hui le
partage des doses est nécessaire lido
sont inégalement répartie il ya des pays
qui ont des surcapacités de
l'assignation par rapport aux besoins
des populations
deuxième élément continuer à optimiser
les capacités de production avec malgré
tout deux préoccupations majeures
maintenir la qualité des produits
partout et sont fabriqués et vous avez
vu la question n'est pas simple mais
aussi des serré par la mobilisation des
gouvernements les contraintes sur les
approvisionnements en matières premier
troisième élément éliminé sous l'égide
de l'om sait toutes les barrières
commerciales et réglementaires à
exportations notamment s'agissant des
matières premières clés des batailles
aux fabrications des raisins et
probablement aussi tout faire pour
faciliter la mobilité internationale de
la main d'oeuvre qualifiée quatrième
élément on n'en a pas parlé jusqu'à
présent mais x pour mu est un enjeu
majeur soutenir sur un plan sanitaire et
sur un plan logistique le déploiement de
la vaccination dans les pays les plus
défavorisés parce que quand bien même
des vaccins seront à disposition il faut
pouvoir organiser cette campagne de
vaccination sur le terrain et on a vu ce
n'était pas simple enfin dernier élément
auquel ce sera mon dernier point
développer l'écosystème d'innovation
pour permettre la mise au point de
vaccins efficaces
outre les vaccins contre les variants
pardon les plus préoccupants il pour ce
faire garantir un accès sans entraves
aux agents pathogènes de tous les
variants du plus vite dix neuf c'est
évidemment un enjeu majeur pour l'avenir
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur philippe lamoureux il
nous semblait extrêmement important de
donner la parole aux entreprises du
médicament vous avez notamment rappelé
l' exploit extraordinaire que représente
la création de vaccins en un temps
absolument record les le danger de
l'émergence de nouveaux variants et donc
la nécessité de poursuivre l'effort
d'innovation des laboratoires et je vous
cite on tuerait dans l'oeuf de
nombreuses innovations prometteuses
selon selon vos propos en enfreignant
cette innovation effectivement il ya
cette dimension des variants et de
risque de 2,2 de pandémie futur c'est
sur lesquels il faut rester absolument
vigilant pour tout c'est pour toutes ces
raisons pour toutes ces précisions nous
nous vous remercions monsieur philippe
lamoureux nous allons maintenant
auditionné le docteur richard benarous
ancien directeur du département maladies
infectieuses de l'institut cochin à
l'initiative de la pétition
la séquence du virus responsable de la
pandémie coville 19 est un bien public
mondial
les vaccins qui en sont issus doivent
l'être aussi
vous avez la parole monsieur benarous
que le président vous m'entendez mais
parfaitement bien oui en nous rendant
très bien donc je vous remercie monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires de m'avoir invité à cette
audition
ma première remarque sera de rappeler
que cette pandémie ou en séquences
absolument catastrophique a pourtant été
annoncée dès 2015 par les chercheurs
spécialisés sur les coronavirus en
particulier par mon ami bruno canard qui
dirigera un moratoire sur les
coronavirus à marseille cependant malgré
ces avertissements malheureusement
l'après
paration au niveau mondial avec total je
crois qu'il faut faire attention à ne
pas reproduire de telles erreurs pour
l'avenir nous sommes tous d'accord pour
dire que donc félicitons de disposer de
vaccins aussi performant aussi
rapidement
ceci grâce à la recherche publique à 20
années de recherche publique et de
recherche industrielle ont bien
maintenues mais les enjeux actuels sont
de deux ordres
on est tous d'accord là-dessus vacciner
massivement dans le monde entier
quand nulle part et d'autre part
vacciner le plus rapidement possible
qu'on n'a pas d'année devant nous on n'a
pas les années comme par exemple
monsieur guerriau rappelé que en 2003 en
2009 la malaisie et le brésil avaient pu
obtenir des antirétroviraux contrôle
final on a pas trois ans 9 ans 10 ans
devant nous on est engagé dans une
course de vitesse avec un virus qui a
toujours un coup d'avancé devant nous et
qui a un bon potentiel de mutation
absolument extraordinaire qu'il a et
qu'il est loin d'avoir épuisé
donc c'est ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
cette course de vitesse il faut il faut
la gagner
donc le problème auquel est vous l'avez
tous rappelé un accord où on a à faire
face c'est qu'on a une pénurie de
vaccins alors comment surmonter cette
pénurie l'accent en ce qui me concerne
et pas seulement ce qui me concerne
puisqu'il ya une centaine de
gouvernement et toute la société squeele
des prix nobel qui ont demandé à ce que
donc pour précisément le nôtre surmonter
cette pénurie de vaccins le
l'ong lève la propriété intellectuelle
sur les sur les vaccins sur les brevets
sur les vaccins en question et je
voudrais juste de demander à monsieur
l'amour qui a peut-être été un peu
expert vraiment excessif de retirer
quand même son allégation sur le fait
que de dire que tout ce qu'ils demandent
la levée des des brevets sont des
complotistes non quand vous regardez
tous ceux qui le demandent
il y en a aucun qui est un complotiste
alors il ya une véritable pénurie une
véritable une énorme disparité dans les
pays en développement aux pauvres il ya
une couverture vaccinale très très
faible voix insignifiante si on continue
comme ça c'est une panne yeux c'est une
pandémie mondiale
on ne pourra pas l'arrivée monsieur
l'amour par les deux du fait que les
sociétés pharmaceutiques actuelle
pouvait produire les producteurs jusqu'à
10 milliards de vaccins d'ici la fin
je vous recommande la lecture de la
meilleure de la plus grandes revues
scientifiques à savoir ledger qui a
précisément dit dans son dans son
dernier dans le dernier volume que le
fmi c'est donc une note rapportés par la
revue des coeurs le fmi considère que
non c'est pas possible que malgré tous
les accords dont les précédents orateurs
ont parlé malgré tout les accords
l'industrie actuellement ne pourra
produire que 6 milliards de doses de
vaccins d'ici la fin 2021 et encore ces
femmes en un maximum
donc on sera toujours en situation de
pénurie par rapport aux besoins et qui
ont été d'ailleurs évoqué par monsieur
monsieur houben qui sont effectivement
de 11 milliards par an
donc malgré les accords de qui ont eu
lieu entre les différentes sociétés etc
on n'y arrive pas on n'a rien on
n'arrivera pas à régler cette pénurie
donc la seule solution paraît elle c'est
de mobiliser l'ensemble de l'industrie
pharmaceutique sous l'égide de l'om est
ce en concertation avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de mobiliser l'ensemble de
l'industrie pharmaceutique mondiale en
capacité bien entendu en capacité et il
y en a de produire ces vaccins il y en a
au sud et au nord
je trouve que par exemple on devrait
s'inspirer de ce qui a été fait pour le
climat et c'est vraiment dommage que ce
qui a été fait pour le climat avec le
giec était avec les coop ne l'a pas été
pour lakovic 19 et qu' on est toujours
un peu dans une situation de un peu
nationalisme vaccinale plutôt que de
coopération globale dans le monde
si on pouvait mobiliser des sociétés
comme gsk bms novartis etc
en france sanofi sermier fabre en russie
en chine dans l'est dans les pays du sud
qui ont des capacités réelles également
en inde en afrique du sud etc
il y as largement dans le monde
aujourd'hui les capacités de répondre
aux besoins mondiaux en ce qui concerne
ces vaccins poli 19 mai pour réussir
cette mobilisation
là il est indispensable de lever les
brevets je suis bien d'accord avec
monsieur bériault c'est pas en lisant un
brevet que vous allez pouvoir réaliser
la production
nos vaccins ou d'un d'un produit
disons médicale c'est vrai les sens il y
a un savoir-faire à voir absolument
et ce savoir faire n'est pas brevetées
et non ça disons
au moulin peu ce que nous disons avec la
pétition que j'ai initié avec le
professeur spirale c'est à dire il faut
voir est-ce que les vaccins sur la s que
les brevets sur les vaccins kobe 19 sont
vraiment légitime il n'y a pas dans ces
vaccins il n'y a pas dans ces brevets de
véritables innovations technologiques
vaccinale ces innovations technologiques
vaccinale ont été dérobés des années des
années avant en particulier
essentiellement aux débats dans le la
recherche publique et ses innovations
vaccinale ont fait l'objet de brevets de
nombreux brevets est bien antérieure à
la pandémie
donc la seule innovation véritable qu'il
y a dans ses brevets le vaccin anti
covin c'est la séquence du virus et sans
cette séquence il n'y a pas de vaccin
possible cette séquence a été lucide et
très très rapidement par les chercheurs
chinois qui ne l'ont pas brevetées donc
cette séquence est un bien public une
ressource publique mondiale il n'y a
aucune raison pour lesquelles les
vaccins qui en sont issus ne soit pas
également considéré comme tel il
j'ajouterai ce qu'on en a parlé aussi on
parle de brevets de deuxième génération
on parle de la nécessité de brevets de
pardon de vaccins excusez-moi de
deuxième génération contre les variants
mais ces séquences des variants on les
connaît grâce à la grâce à la recherche
publique
ces séquences des variants son public
est-ce qu'il est concevable dans ces cas
là que ces séquences de varian soit en
quelque sorte privatisée par
l'intermédiaire de nouveaux prêts je ne
le pense pas je voudrais également
souligner le fait que précisément pour
quelles raisons
les sociétés et enfin un certain nombre
d'internautes insiste sur le fait qu' il
ne faut pas lever la propriété sur les
brevets alors les brevets ne servent à
rien ou pas grand chose disons pour
reproduire un vaccin par exemple c'est
ce que moscou nous a dit entre
parenthèses je dis je tirais à monsieur
bériault enfin je suis d'accord comme
des choses qu'il a qui habite donc mais
ces vaccins c'est de la chimie aussi le
faire en arn
c'est il faut il faut absolument avoir
les nucléotides les briques qui sont
nécessaires à la à l'agencement de ses
arn et tous les intrants dont on a parlé
aujourd'hui ils sont produits dans les
pays du sud
il n'y a dans les pays du nord en france
en particulier et ailleurs il n'y a
pratiquement plus de chimie médicinale
la chimie médicinale on la trouve en
inde en chine et dans neuf pays du sud
donc ces pays là ils ont aussi le droit
qu'on leur permet de et qu'on soirées
comme ça de la coopération avec eux pour
faire les vaccins dont ils ont besoin
voilà et donc ma dernière remarque quand
même ça concerne leur à la france sont
fait excuser moi c'est peut-être du
problème des regrets mais je voudrais
quand même souligner malheureusement que
en france les entreprises
pharmaceutiques ont été aux abonnés
absents sur la colline 19 c'est bien
malheureux mais c'est pas un accident
l'humanité depuis 40 ans fait face à des
fléaux sûr et je parle que de la
virologie en parlant simplement fait de
la virologie fait face à des fléaux
considérable
sur les maladies infectieuses sylla et
pâtit de ces et aujourd'hui co vide 19
l'industrie pharmaceutique française n'a
produit aucun matières et produits
ralenti sylla n'a produit aucun anti
hépatite c et n'a produit pour le moment
aucun vaccin anti communisme est ce que
cette situation n'est pas vraiment
anormal alors que notre pays était d'un
des leaders
tu t'en de russel point de poulenc et
c'est donc je pense que la
représentation nationale le pays dans
son ensemble doit prendre ce problème à
bras le corps il va prendre les
décisions fortes qui s'imposera ce
niveau là à savoir de dison prendre des
décisions sur les structures ont
décision sur la recherche le financement
de la recherche dans les maladies
infectieuses et sur l'organisation des
liens entre la recherche les
biotechnologies et la production les
états unis s'est appelé dans la revue
des jo ou un jour conseils simples sa
lecture
les etats-unis prévoient dans les cinq
ans qui viennent un doublement de leurs
crédits de recherche
je pense qu'il faut faire un effort
analogue en france et c'est d'autant
plus émergents d'autant plus important
que on va faire face à l'émergence de
nouveaux virus est là aussi pour un
malheureux
l'oublier un gros problème avec le
développement de la résistance aux
antibiotiques
donc si on déménage des menaces à
prendre très au sérieux pour l'avenir et
pour conclure sur les brevets je crois
que la france et l'union européenne
serait bien inspiré de suivre le les
états qui demandent la levée est brûlé
et de suivre les etats-unis la russie et
la chine qui ont rejoint c est pourquoi
on demande la levée des brevets si les
brevets de certains et pas tout à fait
exact un qui ne sait pas pourquoi mais
pourquoi on demande la levée des brenets
parce que en fait là le fan si jamais
vous enfin eu une entreprise un pays et
c est serré de dison de s'affranchir de
ce brevet parce que ils peuvent avoir le
savoir faire par ailleurs et c'est ce
qui est d'ailleurs par exemple le cas de
la france
en france on a d'excellents chercheurs
et d'excellents spécialistes et y
compris d'ailleurs sanofi a toutes les
capacités pour développer par exemple
des brevets des vaccins ont tiré rennes
mais dont si ces entreprises la ci cpi
s'affranchissait des brevets même si
c'est pas dans le brevet qu'on va
trouver le vrai le savoir faire
automatiquement il y aura une sanction
considérable au niveau juridique au
niveau financier c'est à dire des landes
pénalités monstrueuses
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle les
entreprises se disent on tiennent
absolument à leurs brevets
mais ça n'est pas l'innovation qui est
qui est vraiment la cause
je rappellerai par exemple simplement
aussi il ya des années des années mais
les vaccin antipolio d'aipac brevets et
des découvreurs de ces vaccins un sort
bine c'est à n'ont pas voulu prendre de
brevets et ils ont eu bien raison
voilà ensuite pour madame la députée je
pense que personne n'a jamais dit que
face étaient seuls les fonds publics
qui finance innovation non effectivement
mais les jeux que je considère que les
entreprises pharmaceutiques finance
aussi l'innovation
mais les fonds publics un finances de
manière considérable et par exemple si
vous voulez on estime on estimé je sais
pas exactement aujourd'hui les chiffres
mais on estime que développer un
médicament le chimique un jeu pas le fun
de vaccins dans lemon au revendeur sa
demande à l'industrie mme parce que
c'est l'industrie qui paye les phases 1
les phases de désastre war c'est un
milliard l'eau c'est l'aube le coup
téthieu lamoureux 3 nous de nous donner
d'autres précisions
mais je vous donne l'exemple des
antirétroviraux contre le sida
ces antirétroviraux en 1 an 2 les
sociétés qui les ont développé elles ont
récupéré leur mise
qu'est-ce que ça et ça fait 10 ans 15
ans que le fond débrouiller absolument
considérable là-dessus prendre un
exemple le l'un des meilleurs
antirétroviral coûte en production 42
euros le traitement annuel
il est vendu dix mille euros en france
quinze mille euros aux états unis 12000
euros en allemagne etc etc pour 800
euros en afrique du sud
mais voilà et ça fait des années que ça
dure donc très bien que l'industrie
fasse des profits
bon mais normaux en quelque sort pas
exagérer c'est tout
[Musique]